what if we could manipulate the weather
just like that will there be no more
hurricanes no storms and floods could we
ease climate change and who would decide
what kind of weather to make this is
what if and here's what would happen if
we could control the weather over 11,000
observation stations around the world
take hourly measurements of temperature
humidity and wind twice a day weather
balloons are launched from 900 locations
to collect the weather information and
transmit it to weather stations every
year the science of weather forecasting
is getting more advanced and still
you're never entirely sure whether you
should take your umbrella in case of
rain the weather is so ever-changing
that even with all our mathematical
models there's only so much we can
predict but what if we knew exactly what
kind of weather to expect every day
because we were the ones creating it
what if I told you that humans can alter
the weather for example cloud seeding a
method in which we add chemicals to the
atmosphere allows us to induce rain to
end droughts or to decrease it to save
the region from hail and hurricanes
chemical additives alter the
microphysical processes within the
clouds and change the amount of
precipitation we can even fire laser
pulses into thunder clouds to trigger
lightning that travels down a controlled
path well the field experiments weren't
exactly successful but at least the
tests in the lab showed that it's
possible of course we can't create the
weather only enhance it the Earth's
atmosphere is so big we can't quite
dictate what it should do but what if we
could that'd be a whole new level of
taking over the planet we would tame
cataclysmic thunderstorms by shooting
our lightning discharging lasers we'd
spill some dry ice to form a supercooled
cloud and prevent a disastrous heat wave
we'd stop tornadoes hurricanes and
floods from taking people's lives and
damaging our property with total control
of the weather farming would thrive dry
season just brew up a refreshing
rainfall too much water just turn off
the precipitation tap
you could buy a house in the tropics and
never have to worry about it getting
ripped away by a storm your plane would
never get cancelled due to bad weather
with scheduled rainfall you'd know
exactly when to take your umbrella with
you maybe you'd even be able to order
someone's favorite weather conditions as
a gift finally we could bring the
earth's temperature back down to what it
was before we started spewing all those
greenhouse gases into the atmosphere
we could probably reverse the climate
change that we humans are responsible
for doesn't that sound awesome being
able to decide the world's weather is
serious business who would control the
weather and who would control the people
who control the weather
well governments might create some sort
of Ministry of weather modification or
private companies might be allowed to
monopolize the weather then they'd get
to decide how much you pay for a sunny
day would the weather be weaponized
could we create bolts of lightning for
personal use and what if countries
started fighting or going to war over
weather priorities there are some
serious threats to consider when taking
over the weather but it doesn't look
like we'll have complete power over at
anytime soon until we do people will
always have something to complain about
wonder what the weather's like on other
planets what if you could teleport
anywhere for a minute to check it out
that's a question for another what-if
[Music]
you